yeah that that's my question tom every
time a big name free agent comes up we
joked earlier earl thomas and javian
clowning are going to end up in in new
england but every time a big name comes
on the market adrian peterson now we
hear oh the patriots are interested the
patriots are interested whether they are
or whether they aren't and mike has this
theory that the patriots were never
interested in leonard fournette they
just kind of threw it out there
how how much of that interest that we
heard about was real and how much of it
was no they're not really interested in
leonard fournette
i think it was much more the latter they
were kicking tires and and finding out
what was out there as any
director of player personnel director of
pro personnel has to do
and it got as mike pointed out very
accurately
agents
teams agents in particular are excited
to always use the patriots as the
stalking horse
to drive up the price now i think what's
interesting is bill belichick looks at
that and says that's fine somebody
overpays or somebody makes a panic buy
on someone that we're not interested in
that's great
and if by extension the player on my
roster who plays that position gets the
vibe that i'm looking to replace him i
don't even have to yell at him today
generally he's going to work even harder
so mike you're exactly right we've seen
it through the years and covering the
team you know whenever any player
of some note
is released
we do deal with a wave of the patriots
interested now they do make plenty of
signings that are
adventurous
and
not what we would expect
and name signings as well
so that's fair too i mean antonio brown
being a perfect example of it um so you
got to stay loose on it
oh volcara
do you see oh both get get uh get ball
on camera come on let's see bo where's
bo
uh while beau arrives let's start
framing another question here oh there's
bo
uh you know what you don't keep it but
no bo
yeah
bo uh beau's very slow bow's like his
dad all right you guys let me ask you
this
go ahead oh all right well so did you uh
earl thomas janevian clowney we joke
that maybe they'll end up on the
patriots do you see any way the dominoes
fall where either of those two two guys
end up in in new england sooner rather
than later wouldn't you damien clowney
have to drop his asking price quite a
bit
the interesting thing is the patriots
are now sitting on about 35 million
dollars worth of rooms having released
muhammad sunu
this week and
they could certainly afford jadav and
clowny i just don't think that they are
in the market right now
for adding big ticket players but
they're always in the market for adding
good players if jadami and clowny was
willing to come in on a year deal
um
i think that that certainly would make
sense as to
earl thomas it's such a young secondary
you got a guy who is
a two-time now loser at his last two
locations as having been kind of a pain
in the ass
so with an impressionable young defense
it's dealing with a ton of opt-outs and
a leadership void i don't know if you
want to bring in earl thomas again in
both instances though
the patriots need better talent on their
roster right now it's not a very
talented roster on either side of the
ball regardless of what they did
defensively last year because of the
free agent exodus
and
the number of optos which was eight and
several key guys on defense
another name tom that was just released
is is adrian peterson and and
again the patriots are in on all these
guys would he be a guy you think did
they need an upgrade at that position
that he would be a guy they might look
at
adrian peterson seems to me to make more
sense than leonard fernett just because
the patriots i were interested a couple
of years ago and the release of adrian
peterson if you look at the patriots
running back room
they're pretty stacked now mike
tannenbaum went as far as to call it the
best running back room in the nfl i
don't think it's that i think it's the
most versatile
um they have players who can do all
things whether it's james white
or rex burkhead who's ver who's uh a
multi-talented back or michelle or
damien harris
but i think adrian peterson still has
something in the tank don't you guys
i definitely think he's still got
something in the tank now he's always
going to think he's got something in the
tank even when he's 75 years old but uh
it's going to be interesting to know
exactly what the story was behind this
do they just think he doesn't have it
anymore was there something else do they
feel more strongly in antonio gibson or
bryce love i don't know but you know
this is the kind of of guy hungry for a
championship that
again if he if he's just above that
basic threshold of what the patriots are
looking for and if he won't get upset if
he doesn't get a lot of touches he just
makes sense to me as somebody the
patriots would want
100 here's the flip side of that mic and
this is the question that we're all kind
of broaching every once in a while are
the patriots still that destination
location in 2020
that a player thinks he's going to be
able to compete for a ring here or was
tom brady the common denominator in that
do those players look at and say well
hightower's sitting out and chung's
sitting out and they lost van noy
and it's just edelman a wide receiver i
don't know how good this team's going to
be
and say i don't want to go up and be in
under the belichick you know regime
which is very
demanding
to go
eight and eight nine and seven seven and
nine
and have happened to me what happened in
the playoffs last year when the patriots
played tennessee so that to me is uh
going to be really interesting as
the years pass here is belichick's you
know certainly in the autumn of his
coaching career are the patriots the
destination that they were
for the last 15 years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports